guys I'm Steve Zaragoza i'm here with
new media rock stars who all you for
friends and this is a very exciting
event we are here for the first new
media rock stars live event at the Jon
Lovitz comedy club universal studios
citywalk it's gonna be awesome I'm
emceeing the damn thing we're doing this
all summer long so join us for this
awesomeness and if you can't make it to
the show there's a streaming link for
each show it's gonna be awesome let's do
it what's up man how you guys feeling
bro real quick which you guys in the
vlog la make some noise yeah I had an
idea what if we bought a lovely lady up
here and we just made up a song about
her can we get a volunteer from the
audience we got ya ear I'm Korea
oh I wanna see you wanna see you maybe
you could date me and we could get it in
cuz i heard you 18 hey it's not hard to
do i put my meat on your grill korean
BBQ from korean hi Hannah Fung Korean
from Korea wait a minute you're the one
on stage that went up on stage has
anyone ever serenaded you know so you're
gonna propose marriage oh tim has a
girlfriend look girl friends aren't like
legally binding type situations guys I
don't know about you but I'm real sweaty
over here you guys sweat no no I'm
sweating big time video bomb was your
favorite part music and comedy I mean
that's where it's at um hello Mia please
speak to Hannah clean my asking calling
my office Tim Tim from school she like
okay cool and then Hannah picks up so
you gotta switch you know i'm saying so
after you after Hannah gets the phone
it's like I know so
it's always great to like these people
after the show and like the people who
really care did you just meet the guys
yes I did what was that like it was
life-changing what was your favorite
part of the whole show Steve yeah I
think I'm gonna quit Facebook's guys and
I'm sick of the baby pictures too I'm
stay always talking about how Aiden does
some cute where's the facebook message
about Aiden taking it on an iPad what
was your favorite part of this um ooh
Andrew Garcia one way ticket one way
ticket
one way ticket one way ticket
what's your favorite condiment to put on
a cheeseburger barbecue sauce okay what
about you what is what's your favorite
thing to put on a cheeseburger ketchup
all right Kayla Maddie I don't want to
see if I could get a little freestyle
out of you like me oh I mean look I know
it's like I know made might not be your
thing yeah you're gonna do it me forever
okay so let's see you do a little
something for her timothydelaghetto all
right I said this is for you Tim if way
around we win that's all I really got
back then but honestly never started
rapping jump on his beat all the mother
laughing dang I didn't get Meryl dirty
but when girls come around a little
flirty wait why's it working silent and
i would love to have a comedian in my
home that's a comedian ghost I would
load up a porn store so guys that's it
for me here with new media rockstar
Steve Zaragoza for the first-ever new
media rock stars live comedy show I
can't wait for you guys to see more of
this stuff it's actually happening all
summer it's gonna be really awesome I
believe it's in the same place right
it's gonna be a jon lovitz comedy club
which is where we are now you can see
the godfather of the club is on this
beautiful painting right behind me but
thank you guys so much for joining me
and I hope you stick around and watch
some more I'm gonna fall down these
stairs real hard and regret my life's
decisions